最近巨人杰跟正大周教授在网络论战
说说我的看法吧
彼者本身也是职业等级的玩家
对他们两个的争论
做出一点个人看法
首先巨人杰在职业领域的成就自然是不用说的
而周教授他不属于交易职业领域
应该说连业余也谈不上
严格说来
用业余的观点去评论职业的领域是不正确的
为什么我这么说呢
因为周教授的说法虽然大部分都对
但关键部分是错的
首先他推崇的被动指数投资这是没有错的
去排斥不同領域的做法
沒錯,就正常人而言
你用周教授的指數投資法
最終的成果普遍會比你自己操作好
但你們發現問題點了嗎?
這是一般人,而對於職業玩家
沒有人會那麼被動的去讓盤式主宰自己的資金
這就像你們看小說的《交易世界》
裡面操作的方法都不是一般你們會使用到的
換句話說,如果隨便的人都能做
那還叫職業玩家嗎?
一個東西如果阿貓阿狗都能進來
會有超額利潤嗎?
而為什麼我在做這影片的當下
支持周教授的人一定會比較多
很簡單,因為你照著作,上面都有賺錢但你想過沒?如果比較極端的狀況發生這種指數投資是不會賺錢的你要賺就是得靠時間來喔你以為台灣不可能出現日本那種跌十幾年的走勢嗎?
任何事情都有可能的
而這就是職業玩家跟一般人想法上的最大差異
再來我們討論一個問題
周教授認為一般人不可能達成巨人節那種地步
所以不建議這麼做
那是特例
這說法我也不知道該說什麼了
舉網球職業領域來說
世界排名前200
你知道這一位住什麼?
这就是整个人类80亿人的前200名
那么如果按照周教授的说法
理论上就不该有职业网友出现
因为你不可能成为职业网球选手
你应该把网球当成娱乐就好
现在
你没有理解这其中的差异了吗
巨人杰跟周教授两个根本不是
同一个空间
同一个时间的人
基本上在基同鸭讲
巨人杰以他亲身的历练
他鼓励的是有为贼一弱势的人
你要挑战自己挑战领域的高峰
本来就该花费大量时间
而且没人能保证你一定成功
如果你甘于平凡
你本就不该吃心妄想
乖乖当个一般人就好
其实我是觉得巨人节
根本不用理会周教授
根本就是不同世界的人
也没有共同语言
何必因为别人怎么想
而想去说服别人呢
我从十几年前就不干这种事了